[Music]
in toxic workplace news Oh cuz I don't
have one of those okay submitted by JK
is cool oh thank you very much a Court
rejects a lawsuit and rules that farting
is not considered bullying who it is
okay I'm like before you even tell this
story I'm picturing like a guy that
comes into work every day and somebody
he doesn't like when they come in like
they just start farting like it's like
to be rude you know and then eventually
he like you know reports them to HR or
something and they say we can't do
anything you know what's kind of
ridiculous is like when somebody they'll
it's really hard for you right and it's
like it's like funny the first few times
but then they get so comfortable they
just fart every 10 seconds it's like I
don't think it's funny ever now you're
overstepping your bounds well sometimes
it is the sound of it the sound of it is
very funny sound I never think it's
funny because I'm like the thoughts that
go my pants I hear it and then I picture
butthole opening up your picture yes
that's why I think it's just not have to
open up her ear to what are you talking
about like this I don't say wide open
the very close because it's so tight
it's got to have the air the butthole is
not what makes the toys it's the booty
cheeks that are flattening in between
because if you white and you spread your
budget sound like this I have a dog that
[ __ ] bricky who keeps her [ __ ]
tail up should her tail is naturally up
all the time so I'm like good for your
boy yeah that's a great time for spotted
bodily yeah but her her [ __ ] looks like
a angry sea anenome
that's a butthole yeah her buckles
unique though that's a butthole that
doesn't mean it opens up yes it does
well I mean I get her logic it has to
open the message this have you ever
laughed and farted yes
No you never get honestly you don't know
the pleasures of it what are you
laughing for it that is very so funny
that you usually laugh even more after
this guy knows what he's talking about
yeah it was like a snort when people
laugh and they snort in a new laugh you
know what the biggest blessing is is
when you have to fart and then you have
one of these that didn't just draw
attention to yourself so there was this
case a 1.8 million dollar negligence
case but it was thrown out cuz the judge
is like farting isn't bully that guy is
a waste of [ __ ] time
the judge has never smelled farts parts
what did you spots a little bit it still
works both ways though cuz you put the
first letter brain is run by this great
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] profoundest but
you've never seen any force parts this
[ __ ] never happened prior to her
pregnancy did you notice that like music
operated this [ __ ] started happening
babies take all your brain news Oh
[ __ ] smarts right employee David he
alleged I his supervisor at a
construction engineering place would
repeatedly abuse
him including by holding him down and
party I thought he was just walking in
his office like farting and then like
leaving and I close they also like
cupcake intuition that's where you catch
it in your hand you throw in their
[ __ ] face that works
[ __ ] good know the proper way to do
it is slowly thank you honey you're
gonna [ __ ] disgust it happened to me
and I passed on the joy of that Oh so
would you be okay I asked have you done
it you said no so what you do is when
you're watching a movie shoot my kitchen
my perception of you are in front of
each other
hold on the fuel I wouldn't do it if you
watch okay who did I [ __ ] marry you
know because you like [ __ ] anybody
cupcake what you want to do is this what
you want to do this when you're watching
a movie pretend like you're watching and
you look over and you have to time their
breathing then you fart and you cup and
you hold on to it right hold on to it
and as soon as they exhale you put it
right on their mouth and they're gonna
breathe the whole thing in and it's
gonna be the worst feeling ever
that's not a cupcake that's it you got
enough remote your green homie yes how
does he know about this [ __ ] so well do
the [ __ ] Creed homies oh this stupid
[ __ ] like that [ __ ] I inhaled the
[ __ ] shittiest air in the entire
world so this whole time we were saying
why people [ __ ] we should have been like
Korean [ __ ] well Korean people don't do
it to strangers though you do it to your
close friends they go to random people
there's a problem yeah they do they go
to school a shoe random people Korean
shooter was [ __ ] they're friends that's
true
take it there like it's not even to go
back under bring your back
alright so that's what the victim was
alleging right the employee was alleging
wait wait can you read one more time so
he would hold him down and force him is
what he's alleging so he claimed that it
resulted in depression anxiety and
physical injuries and claimed that 1.8
million in damages as part of an unfair
dismissal case that's what he's claiming
that it's unfair that they dismissed it
so the judge is saying that there's no
way you can get depression and anxiety
from someone farting on you he was
saying that by 40 farting isn't bullying
yeah that's what holding somebody on
them is pretty much good mrs. [ __ ] if I
came into working bar I was like what if
it was stiff though still sound like a
fun boss though yes then the victims
saying that whenever he would be around
supervising that he'd lift up his leg
and like fart towards him and that at
one point he called the employee called
the supervisor mr. stinky and that he
went up to him and like sprayed
oh he's asking to get his ass beat
though right yeah it turns out that
they're saying here that the victim
because he's of German descent he
doesn't understand Australian sense of
humor because apparently for them like
it's just funny to fart and I love how
they don't like the cultural differences
yeah it's Jenny's a little weird hearts
are just sparks regardless of what
country is on me you're not supposed to
follow anybody yeah it's just weird
it didn't a workplace what in the [ __ ]
exactly it's kids of mom Australian mate
but I think if I was in the workplace
right and then my boss came up in like
farted on me once I feel like haha
alright Rick you know whatever whatnot
right thank you great the second one is
that a bro it's kind of gross stop just
being Australian Australia with that
[ __ ] I'm like alright cool I'm just
gonna be American I'm gonna [ __ ] you up
and that's how we're gonna deal with him
right you know I mean cultural clashing
[Laughter]
yeah so then the judge rejected claims
of malice flatulence and saying that it
was an offense that has its origins and
cultural differences rather than the
sort of feared distress simulation or
victimization that one would ordinarily
expect in a bullying scenario because
the boss the supervisor Greg was saying
that like he doesn't remember doing that
at all like he doesn't pinning someone
down partying on them yes like that was
kind of that was like breezed over in
the article the fact that he was
claiming that he was held down so I
don't know any more details about that
or like how they justified that but
apparently the whole thing about like
him intentionally farting near him was
dismissed because the the supervisors
like I mean I might have farted once or
twice and I do remember a one in one
occasion that I did apologize for
farting by accident yeah that's a great
defense though I'm just saying one time
I did something wrong I called my dad I
was like what do I do he was like did
anyone see it and I was like no he was
like you didn't do it
you weren't there feel great more my
family is great more you don't remember
anything it works man really does our
friendship Rob what do you mean geo what
do you mean that what did you find metal
Wayne yeah the Sun nothing else where's
your kid right now
exactly no I didn't see I didn't hear
anything
I could imagine like Australian farts
being pretty stinky though just because
I know that Australia also has like a
high like morbid obesity rate just like
America knows I think I think they're
fat problem is actually worse than
America's we just have more fat people
because we have more people but their's
is pretty bad out there
apparently so I could imagine just fat
people farts oh isn't it hot huh yeah
it's hot
does that make farts worse oh yeah dude
have you ever [ __ ] farted in the
shower
I read something that if you're if
you're like in a humid environment and
like there the humidity is like on your
nostril hairs I get intensifies oh for
sure dude so it's not really the I mean
probably temperature but it I feel like
the fact that the the fat fart particles
are attaching to the Steve yeah that's
what I picture yes if they're holding on
to them exactly they're just like you're
like well where are you going homie and
they just grab on yeah yeah I hate that
[ __ ]
[Music]